the perpetrators were luc frieden sheikh by
hand for me it was always a
matter of course to practice the commandments of god
and not to
question too much why you didn't
doubt that in the five six years that
you were basically in this scene simply out of
fear of committing blasphemy
out of fear  doing something wrong because
i was completely new to this
religion and didn't know anything at first
and then just
trusted or had to trust the people around me
and then over
time you researched more and
sometimes into other islamic religions  directions and
ways of thinking a little bit of a
sniff and seen aha
it's not all that easy
as it was presented to you
extreme pressure that's about like you
come into this world looking for something
but you don't know what you're looking for and
you can be lucky but  had no
meaning in life if you don't know
where to go i just
answered that  et with things that you just
learned by heart so, things
that you kind of kind of
always repeated I heard again and again
I had the expansion spoken
out and gave
the answer
and how the group would record a video like this
so who does more to the
initiative  for saying
i didn't want to do that at all he then
said that it was my duty as
a german to pass my fate on to the people, so to speak, as a role model as a motivation for the non-
practicing muslims that in
germany that doesn't mean all that
munich
i had a conversation with
he made contact with me
but when it was just beginning to become a
little more familiar so
because he knows back then yes yes yes that
was cool and suddenly you can like
that katja i just wanted to
say goodbye to her i  report whatsapp deselection
had been informed you said what should
i do in germany
i have the islamic state
i  is that what i want
the caliphate an islamic life what
do i want in germany
what does that
matter to him is important then it just hurts
it is half a person who
meant a lot to me or the person
i knew at the time still means to
me  a lot but it will certainly no
longer be the person it used to be so
alone a war doesn't
let you assume you might be under so you're
under somehow this state of shock
no idea how you feel a war
so probably not exactly
nice unless you  stop listening every day
yes we do it for god and
when we die then paradise can
you imagine being able to kill
no idea
right say
dear viewers as a young person who
feels lonely or problems with the
family with the school and stuff  further,
the one who doesn't know where it's going, knows
he feels totally comfortable in this scene
because you also feel comfortable until
you or as long  If you hold the same
views,
would you call that
brainwashing or is it something
like a cult,
so I would say there are definitely
sectarian traits without you
really breaking away from society
that you are only with your own kind
that you only  still has an input
messages are always suggested
such as you can watch
tv so tv is not available but
the content is naked women music etc
fitness studio is not hard but
you are not allowed to go there because
exercising undermines women music zone
or friendship with  copper isn't
approaching but it would be better if you don't associate
with them like that and that's
a manipulation to me
so said the bbs got here come
here that's like a call of duty just a
real that's definitely a youth
subculture and pop culture ingrained years
ago  is and that this as
actionism carries with it not that
you only play it but contribute  we can
experience i think that the whole valley too
many young people
are looking for a certain meaning who have not had any
success in life but who then get the
message come to the ws here
you can eat instead of here you can
really live islamic and you
can buy goods  also exercising power here
you can really achieve something and if
you have failed in the west it is
irrelevant here to us to the
muslim community i don't
know i just saw you in the video
but in the video this
excerpt about the hard important but
we  have us before